hangtime my life in basketball with one
of the all-time greats Elgin Baylor it
is right here on the desk and it is
should be in your in your hands right
now reading hang time my life and
basketball Elgin Baylor here in person
on the Rich Eisen show good to see you
sir thank you what a pleasure why this
book by now one hang time now no you
know people been asking me there's been
years
you know since who I've retired you know
right in the book and I said nope I'm
not you know it's right in the book and
I was thinking you know a lot of
personal things happened in my life you
know they didn't want to discuss it I'll
get into it you know details thing so I
just kept putting it off putting it off
but you know putting it off and so away
from now we sat down and talked about it
you know and she very encouraging things
so she said you know you should write a
book so I decided to do it
mm-hmm sit down and now and now that
this is all out here are you concerned
about putting some of this personal
stuff in here no so then what's the most
what would you say is the the item that
was most concerning to you about putting
in a book that you did put in this book
I don't know write tough money I can't
think of any of it II you know with the
name Donald sterling believe to my all
sterling I forgot about that it's not
something that's the top of your mouth
not at all what was it like working for
him
Elgin well it was very very you know
difficult but you know wasn't easy
because he's the type of guy that would
change his mind you never know from what
mood he's in from one to next in an X
and you get sit down talk discuss you're
gonna do one thing and next thing you
know he's gonna decide okay we're not
gonna do it and so it was you know very
difficult it was it wasn't easy
especially signing players you know that
means you had to start paying some money
and Don didn't like to be paying the
money and that was the toughest part you
know signing signing players well I mean
in this book just reading reading it the
moment that you described just with
Danny Manning right after you drafted
one of the all-time greats from Kansas
and he's now gonna come to Southern
California was a big moment for the
Clippers organization to have somebody
Danny Manning's character and someone of
Danny Manning stature come off of a
national championship run with Larry
Brown who is obviously very familiar to
Los Angeles basketball fans can you walk
my listeners and viewers through that
part of your book here what happened
with Danny Manning
well well Danny came in and his contract
was up and you know as he and his agent
came there and they want to discuss you
know salary which is normal and don't
didn't want to pay him but really he
writes wait for they deserved because
Danny was at burg you know good player
here's the first clear pick in the draft
and Don didn't want to pay him the money
that that he wanted you know in his
agent I thought it was very very
reasonable in fact I thought it should
have been more than he was asking for
but I didn't want to get into it because
I once dollars always concerned about
money so I said hey you know maybe you
can save some money and so you know sat
down and discussed it so Danny Danny you
know had his agent we sat there and we
talked talked and talked and finally you
know Donald said well just at the point
where this you know the negative remark
that he made in the book about Danny man
you know you know some time I tried to
get it out of my head some time I just
even forget it was he referred to his
race is 40 right right the poor black
black kid I don't know if he said kid a
boy but there's a lot of money and that
was a reasonable amount cuz it was just
a little bit above the average salary
that players were making and Danny was
an all-star play he made the all-star
team and it was a good you know
basketball player and when Donald said
that you know you know I was just
shocked you know that he would say
something like that especially to him to
his face now you'd say something like it
may be to the agent if the agent is not
around but to say something like that
you know and it was very upsetting how'd
you put the pieces back together well
Danny you know Danny you know end up get
you know leaving the traded you know and
you know Danny never recovered from it
his agent so and it was difficult
because the agent you know when you're
trying to get players make deals you had
to go through the agent say and then
when he's doing something like that and
you know it's tough you know trying to
patch it up you know
it wasn't that easy you know and and
then it was difficult trying to get
players to come to the team because of
that you know that was nationwide
everybody read about it knew about it
and when you talk to you know agents
they said well listen I don't want my
player Ben McDonald still it was very
difficult to get players you know unless
the guy was this desperate you needed a
job are the Clippers cursed Elgin Baylor
you know I you know and I don't believe
in stuff like that curses know that
stuff but you know I don't you know I
just think if you're good enough it's
going to happen it doesn't happen you
know one of the reasons because you
don't have the ability to do it but as
you say curse you know it could be Elgin
Baylor here on the Rich Eisen show hang
time my life and basketball what was it
like moving with the Lakers from
Minnesota to here in Los Angeles well
you know you know I got drafted I was
the first picked in the draft fortunate
and so I was just happy to uh be drafted
you know I didn't realize that would be
the first pick in the draft
and so in Minneapolis Minnesota there's
a wonderful city the people were just
this wonderful grateful and everything
else because they'll invite me to the
dinner and everything else but the
problem was that wasn't a major problem
it was no it was snow every night you
know every morning you wake up you know
the street sleepers are sweeping the
snow and everything on it was cold I
mean we get like 29 28 29 degrees below
zero but the people were really nice the
city with clean city and I was just
there for no season right you know and
get an opportunity to move elsewhere and
what happened we just before this you
know season start you know when you go
around have a training camp and we play
exhibition games and so I sit and so we
decided to go out to California came out
can't sit in Bakersfield California and
I had never been there before
and I said man you know wouldn't it be
great if they had a team out here see
and never thought about it and we moved
back and we came back home next thing I
know down still we're moving out there
to California
could not believe it because it was 25
below zero when I left Minneapolis and
now 10 Bakersfield it was like but 85
degrees and I said wouldn't it be nice
and we have a team out here or is there
any Showtime hello no no Showtime out
here and not for the first not really
first started no soul shield Elgin
Baylor here on the Richardson show most
talented teammate you ever had was who
man you see the talented teammate no no
players well I would say Jerry Jerry
would be one Jerry West yeah you know
naturally trying to think you know how
about the best player you ever played
against best play ever play against out
you know get them trying to get back
some you know Thunder players because I
don't want to make any I'm sad I didn't
pick them you know understood the what
now right what was the question
no the best player you've ever played
against yes well you know it depends on
what you're looking for in the player if
I had to pick one player to start a
franchise yes you know and I want to win
championships no one would ever guess
you know I've asked people that question
they ask and then I'm ever guess who I
would take and you you know you take a
guess who you think I would take of all
time in the Hall the praise in history
wilt know Russell right Bill Russell
Bill Russell that 111 I think are 13
years champs of every year in the year
he didn't win a champ so he was hurt I
mean the guy was just incredible and
think about it seeing people look at the
score look at statistics yeah and
Russell statistics wasn't that bad cuz
nobody that took in it didn't take shots
he was shooting a high percentage
because most of his shots
we're dunks in time you know inside the
key and the guy was incredible
I mean the way you know the way he
played you know and people were just
shocked I said Russell and then just
look at such ads and see guys they have
12 13 points again but look at the
intangible things hey he gonna save you
30 or 40 points who's the player that's
playing in the NBA today Elgin Baylor
that could have held it his own in the
league while you were playing and
the balls in your diet LeBron James I
mean he says like a freak of nature I
mean this guy man he's built like
Hercules I mean he's six eight and to
think he waited like 275 was 280 and he
should be out there playing football -
but I mean he is one heck of an athlete
what about Westbrook with all the triple
doubles we're hearing the name my second
name and dodge
Westbrook would be I mean if you know
first guard would be it's tough you know
because Jerry West was a terrific player
too you know and an Oscar was a terrific
you know player too and off Oscar C
would have the advantage because of his
size
you know Oscars you know could a
football I mean this is a big you know
strong guy but I take and I say either
one of them you know play with either
one if I take either one they got from
your arrow who would have been the best
at shooting threes if she was in three
and there was a three-point line that
that's you know yeah yeah and I don't
know I'm trying to think of it you know
the shooters there's a lot of good
shooters but the 3-point line who would
take whoever was do you prefer the game
with the three-point line
know what I you know they'd see what's
what the fans enjoy you don't people
want what about you come like they're
doing George it's a little percentage
shot there's not a high percentage shot
you know because you know when we played
you know we were taught if you have a
shot open shot give you 20 feet out you
know try to get within 16 feet is 16 try
to get within 12 you know then you get
going on you know you've got get as
close to the hope as you can see that's
why we're trying to do in case you
missed you can follow them try to get
your own rebound which I did a lot of
the time right you know but when it all
comes down to it though it's a low
percentage just a low percentage shot
three at three-point shot it's a low but
a lot of guys are proficient because
Kari is just phenomenal and I never seen
anyone shoot like that and in my life I
mean he's just incredible I mean this
guy just gets the ball and he shed his
eyes I know I seem to do that
it closed his eyes and and run up the
court before hang time Elgin Baylor is
new memoir my life in basketball and
there you are on the cover
wearing number 22 what's it like to have
that bronze statue outside of well you
know no because I know when they first
put the statues up in the other statues
and I didn't have a statute you know I
would always get people asked so why
don't you have a statute wants to have
stats and I really didn't think about it
I mean didn't bother me I was just happy
that I've had a career you know real
good career and now that you know they
put up a bit I'm very grateful of it you
know appreciate yeah and it looks like
you're going to the you go under the rim
right there and where there was cream
out there with Shaq Jerry West my gosh
well I mean that is a no that isn't some
all-time great lineup sitting right out
there Elgin thanks again for coming in
here really appreciate you sharing some
memories and everybody should go buy
this book oh thank you thank you for
taking the time Elgin Baylor one of the
all-time greats to go hang time my life
and basketball the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience